jonathan has asked his question like 18
times in the chat he really needs an
answer to this question so Jonathan I
appreciate the hustle this question is
for you how does one select people for
our diverse team which you can trust and
grow with hey Gentiles great question
and I think that there is something
there's no easy answer to as an
entrepreneur because you know I've made
many decisions and some bad decisions
over the time and I'm sure we all have
but I think that this the smart way to
answer days you know obviously I think
number one is look for the differences
you need to be successful be quite
conscious of that in and you know I'm
picking sort of D biased you mind and
then pick the individual and and the key
thing is with all these things is you
have to be aligned around the mission
you have to be aligned around the
purpose you know if you want to go into
the music business and the individual
doesn't like music you're going to
struggle so they've got at they've got
to bring something but but the most
important thing is you've got the
alignment and the power of the purpose
the sense of purpose the center passion
because you know being entrepreneurs
hard work and you do have to work really
hard to be successful and if they don't
have that fire in their belly that
you've got about your big idea then you
know you might as well shut the
conversation down straight away then
once they've got that I think then you
got to ask yourself what is the
complementary skill set was the
competence what's the experience that
they bring to your success and that's
very dependent on where you are in your
journey if it's the ideas they did
probably blue sky it's probably at a
partner if it's further down in your
sort of business journey then it could
be around you know sales marketing
social media it could be a very good SEO
optimization it could be you know what
is it you need at that stage I think you
should be very thoughtful about that and
then the next thing is kind of making
that transition going with it and then
you know honestly are the best device to
give you is if you make a mistake
eeeek make the mistake to learn early
you know just as just as we do in terms
of ideas we have a culture where we we
want to encourage all our colleagues to
fail fast and again as Spotify just a
data point they have sort of an ideas
Factory they expect like nine out of ten
ten ideas to fail but one idea will be a
kind of absolute kind of bastard a
ripper and they'll be shooting
successful that one idea but I think it
was in the culture of a great company
again you want to encourage people to
fail there's no there's no fear of
failure but ultimately if it doesn't
work out as an individual down the road
then it's really important to just sit
down and be transparent authentic and
just say you know it's kind of just not
working out with you well you know we
I've made a bad hard decision you know I
apologize for that but we just got to be
honest with ourselves yeah and and the
great entrepreneurs I think you know are
always sort of focused on their business
almost to a level of ruthlessness but
they're always very compassionate with
the people around them and very
authentic about that agree with
everything even saying the thought that
I'm going through in my head just to add
to it is I like testing people on
different projects I think if you can
find an easy way to get tested so give
them an assignment so whether you're
bringing on interns or whether you're in
your hiring process I'm not a big fan of
the typical job interview process I'd
rather to let them get to work on
something and see how would see how it
goes and so it'd give them five hours to
work on a project and see what comes up
and be willing to be surprised and open
to new ideas and so if you have some
kind of way to test people out on a
small short-term basis and again the
signs point of you're lying on the
mission you here's our goal because
we're trying to get to but I'm up with
the how the path how we're going to get
there if you can find ways to work with
people and test them out to see what
ideas might come out I think you'll be
surprised a lot of the people who are on
my team I have a team of misfits like
they would have a hard time getting a
job other places they had the worst
resumes their cover letter were you know
wasn't great but I just gave them a
chance and they surprised me
because often the skills if you're
hiring a video editor their cover letter
doesn't really make a big difference I'm
not hiring them for their writing
ability I want to know they can make
great videos and so the Stevens point
about not falling into stereotypes and
just giving people a test I think you'll
be surprised if you do that with enough
people